remember when the New York Mayor freed a
bunch of inmates because he feared they
might get the coronavirus well at least
50 hit the street to victimize the naive
civilians who elected him mind-blowing
right so how did this dim-witted garment
bag of dirt respond quote I think it's
unconscionable just on a human level
that folks were shown mercy and this is
what some of them have done shocker
I went to the thugs for comment but they
were deeply hurt that the mayor found
their actions unconscionable and swore
that from now on they'll never mug again
if the mayor lets them out give some
tickets to the next Mets game and a hug
de Blasio will address the offer after
he hits the gym across town kidding I
think I normally avoid ad hominem
attacks but de Blasio is not an actual
hominem he's a walking stack of stupid
like Jenga with feet he's literally the
biggest joke in American politics it
sucks that in a nation of adults were
ruled by idiot children who choose to
ignore the links between actions and
consequences remember as Corona spread
he implored people to lead normal lives
and now his own actions spread crime
like a virus and let's not forget this
clowns advice for citizens who see
others failing to social distance think
on him when you see a crowd when you see
a line that's not distance when you see
a supermarket that's too crowded
anything you can report it right away so
we can get help there to fix the problem
and now it's as simple as taking a photo
all you got to do is take the photo and
put the location with it and bang send a
photo like this and we will make sure
that enforcement comes right away Wow
he loves his Stassi so first he tells
people to ignore the virus then he sets
loose thugs on the city then he asks of
fellow citizens to turn into narcs what
a creep someone should take a picture of
him and hang it at every post office the
number one most unwanted mayor or toss
it in the bottom of a urinal and flatter
him I'd say lock him up but then he'd
only release himself to a parade that he
arranged only to reoffended a later date
all right Juan this is a city I think
that I think I know the problem here
this is a city in which the politicians
don't have a healthy opposition so the
weaker incompetent candidates can
stretch the limits of their own failures
because there's no like normal moderates
Democrats left I don't know
right you know you got a point I don't
like any city that lacks that kind of
political tension and a lot of the big
cities are now in a situation where you
have Democrats who just rule and I think
you've got to have some kind of
challenge I mean it's interesting in New
York
AOC Alexandra Ocasio cortez now has a
more conservative Democrat willing to
run against her will see how that plays
that Greg yeah but to your point I mean
I think it's a real problem for us as an
American people rule by a constitution
it says no cruel and unusual punishment
what do we do with people who are in
prisons which oftentimes can become you
know petri dishes for the spread of
disease so you don't want to say hey
you're condemned and you have to stay
there especially if you're not charged
with a violent crime but then what
happens when they get out and do commit
another crime because people are going
to say hey you let that guy back out on
the street you doofus you but from my
perspective I think look New York's
crime rate has not gone up it's gone
down since this since we've gone into
sheltering to protect ourselves against
the virus in fact this is a global
reality that crime has gone down and I
think you have to keep that in mind okay
but okay so there is a solution Jesse do
you remember Sheriff Arpaio built those
tents like you can I mean instead of
saying hey boy let them go why don't why
can't you build a temporary place I mean
we're it's been done yeah didn't he make
him wear like pink underwear
that is our pail it is best I remember
that guy I mean come on criminals commit
crimes was shocking revelation Maher
soon he's gonna find out that babies cry
and women
jealous and fat people like to eat I
mean what is this guy's his first day on
planet Earth he's like the parents that
leave his teenage son alone in the house
for the weekend come back and can't
believe he threw a party oh my god I
mean oh my god could you believe that I
mean listen if I was the mayor and there
is a covert outbreak in the prison would
I release everybody from the prison
though they're sheltering in place I
would keep them there I would treat them
and I would test and treat the guards
it's not that it's not that crazy the
other thing is to the narking thing you
call it a Fink to narc this guy said
don't go to gyms and workout during this
pandemic the next day he was
photographed at a gym working out you
know what his excuse was well I'm the
mayor I have to stay in shape and be
healthy till guide the city but he
hasn't guided a thing the governor
totally eclipsed them yeah I agree with
almost everything you said but I will
say men can also get jealous and skinny
people like to eat to more jealous hey
Greg you saved them I think Greg saved
you Jesse he's holding your hands I
couldn't reach I don't make ad hominem
attacks though Greg I don't make ad
hominem attack you just make blanket
statements hey doc doc the mayor wants
to have a parade which I know that it's
a noble thought for for responders and
hospital staff after this but is it
really wise to have a large massive
event once you reopen the city you just
have to look at what happened with st.
Louis in Philadelphia when they decided
to do a parade after the 1918 the
Spanish flu Philadelphia said they were
gonna do it st. Louis said not
Philadelphia had a massive spike in
cases again and a lot of deaths occurred
but in terms of the prison population
and people being reoffending mean the
2018 but Bureau of Justice Statistics
actually
that about 68% of people released from
prisons will we'll get back put back in
within three years for committing a new
crime so it's it's not even like we
flipped a coin whether or not people
were gonna commit crimes again so yeah I
agree with Jesse they need to be much
smarter about this and they just were
not you know Dana I think that de Blasio
success is based on all the work that
was done before him with Bloomberg and
Giuliani he it's like they gave him an
expense account of a healthy City and he
says she's spending it everywhere he's
like he's got so much to work he's that
guy on in a bike race that just tucks in
behind the leader and coasts right
through he's probably one of the only
haven't seen the numbers but most mayors
and governors approval ratings have gone
way up across the board but I think that
he is probably the the nation's worst
mayor yes I think I think it's fair to
say that I don't know if that's a
blanket statement or an ad hominem
attack I just think it's a fact
that's you know and when Dana the nicest
person on earth says you're the worst
mayor in the United States it's probably
true because she doesn't ever say stuff
like that okay